hey this is press tow
Walker here's a fun problem start with
square
ABCD the square has a side length equal
to
four construct a quarter Circle centered
at B that connects A and
C then construct a semicircle with a
diameter equal to a
d the quarter Circle and the semicircle
overlap what is the area of the overlap
between these two
shapes this problem caused quite a stir
because it was shared on social media
with the tagline that it was asked in a
primary school in
China but even in China this was felt to
be extremely difficult for a primary
school
question from what I could tell Primary
School in China could mean as high as
year six which would be students aged 11
or 12 now I want to thank Blake who
suggested this problem to me he was
saying some of his calculus students in
America were having trouble solving this
problem so what's the
answer pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem a try when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this
problem so how can we work this out we
will begin like many geometry Problems
by making a few constructions that will
make the calculation easier start with
the center of the quarter Circle the
quarter Circle has a radius that's equal
to the side length of the square which
is four construct a radius to the
intersection point of the quarter circle
with the
semicircle this radius will also have a
length that's equal to
four then construct the center of the
semicircle the diameter of the
semicircle is equal to four so its
radius will be half of that and equal to
two construct a radius to the
intersection point and this length will
also be two now connect the
centers from here we are going to
calculate the area of the overlap
between these two
shapes it will be equal to the area of
the circular sector of the
semicircle then we're going to add the
area of the circular sector of the
quarter
Circle so now we counted too much area
so we've counted the overlap twice and
we've also counted the areas that are
outside the overlap contained in this
kite so we need to subtract out that
entire area so we need to subtract out
the areas of these two right
triangles this simple equation will give
us the area of the overlap so All That
Remains is to calculate the areas of
these shapes let's start with the
easiest calculation which will be the
areas of the
triangles so the area of a right
triangle will be equal to2 its base
times its height in this case we can
take 2 and 4 so this will be 1 12 * 2 *
4 1 12 of 2 is equal to 1 * 4 is equal
to 4 so the area of a single right
triangle is equal to four but we have
exactly two of them and they will be
congruent to each other so this right
triangle will also have an area that's
equal to
four the total area of two triangles
will be 4 + 4 which equals 8 so far so
easy now what's the area of a circular
sector it's equal to 12 * the radius squ
* Theta where the angle Theta is in
radians so here comes a tricky part we
know the radius of this is equal to two
but what is the central angle equal to
we will need to use a little bit of
trigonometry to calculate this so we'll
take a look at this right
triangle now let's say that this angle
is
T what is the measure of angle
T it will be equal to the arct tangent
of the opposite side divid by the
adjacent side so that's the AR tangent
of 4 2 which is equal to the arc tangent
of
two now in this right triangle this
angle is also equal to T so the total
central angle will be equal to
2T so the formula for the area of this
sector will simplify to be 12 * r^ 2 *
2T now 12 * 2T will simplify to be just
T so now we can just substitute it so
this is equal to r^ 2 * T the radius is
equal to 2 2^2 is equal to 4 and T is
equal to arctangent of 2 so this equals
4 * the AR tangent of 2 and we figure
out the area of one circular
sector we just need to do the same thing
for the other circular
sector so we calculate the area of this
circular sector in a similar fashion
using the same Principle as before let's
take a look at this right triangle and
let's say that this angle is equal to S
we also have a congruent right triangle
here so this angle will also be equal to
S as before the area of the circular
sector will be 12 * r^ 2 * the central
angle in this case the central angle is
2 * s so the 1/2 and the 2 s will cancel
so the area of the circular sector will
be equal to r^ 2 * s but what is s we
don't need to go through every
calculation again because we've already
calculated T So T was equal to AR
tangent of 2 and since we have a right
triangle s and t are complimentary
angles so s+ T will be equal to Pi over2
radians so s is equal to Pi / 2 minus t
which is equal to the AR tangent of 2 so
we can substitute into the formula we
have R is equal to 4 and S is equal to <
/ 2 minus the AR tangent of 2 so r^ 2
will be 4^2 which equal 16 this is
multiplied by the entire group term Pi /
2 minus the AR tangent of 2 we can
distribute the 16 so 16 * piun / 2 will
be equal to 8 piun and then we have
minus 16 * the arctangent of 2 so we get
8 piun - 16 * the AR tangent of 2 and
that's the area of this other circular
sector All That Remains is we need to
put this all into one
formula so the area we want is 4
arctangent of 2 plus 8 Pi minus 16 arang
2 -
8 we can now have 4 arctangent of 2us 16
arang of 2 that simplifies to be minus
12 arctangent of 2 so the final formula
is 8 piun - 12 12 * the AR tangent of 2
- 8 which is approximately equal to
3.84 S and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh